I would say that in the job we
do we are often confronted
with the fact of presenting results to
our superiors to people coming
from outside
and often we have to explain these
results
not necessarily with mathematics which
are  not understandable by all and
therefore suddenly one of the major advantages
in my opinion of mathematica is the
possibility of graffiti in two
dimensions three dimensions to be able to
manipulate graphic objects very
easily and also it must be admitted that
they are quite pretty so it  does it
make a good impression vis-à-vis
the outside vis-à-vis the people who
explain all this so it has been for a few
years that we hopper I have been working on
the sidelines in the popular within
the risk department  financial officers in
charge of second-level risk control
we have both undergone
training in financial mathematics
and our activity will focus
on assessment monitoring management  on
financial risks related to
market activities dance in this
risk assessment we will find in particular the monitoring
the definition of limits and
risk indicators but also
remy who finally everything
concerning questions a little more quantitative
risk management validation of  models
independent evaluation of models and
creation of pricing tools
for risk monitoring that they have done
with mathematica as you can
see
we are really focused on
mainly quantitative
risk level and the great strength of
mathematica c  is allows us to
focus just on the
mathematical side of things all the
probabilistic statistical libraries
all the links all the all the links
with the databases with the
excel files with different
environments are already all integrated
we don't care anymore  from that we put a
model on paper and we
immediately implement m  athematics in
mathematica which will allow us to
immediately take advantage of the
computing power of the formal language really
adapt very quickly to the different
needs of the market and more in parallel
before moving to mathematica we were
oriented towards technologies like java
or more simply with  bb1 is
in the process in fact towards the
pricing of the complex product it turned out
that there could be problems in terms
of calculation time and reliability of the
results
so a little naturally in fact we
turned to mathematics to
thomas had already  had an experience
on it and he actually proposed to switch
to mathematica and then later it
turned out that it was really the right
choice we gained in
store productivity in terms of quality of
results
and that's it  it was beneficial in
fact yes an important thing all the same
it is that mathematics apart from the
environments which is proposed we were
even driving
new ideas in particular the creation
of an intranet platform since
mathematics at wolfram mathematica
also offers web mathematica which
allows the use of all these tools
on a web jsp technology therefore very
very suitable on an
intranet platform the banking sector and in
particular  quantitative analysis therefore
naturally idriss pricing and jill
who offer us complex models
therefore they will allow us they
will very quickly allow
our management to have models which
will allow us to benchmark and the
models of our others  directions and all
that with an integration in
mathematica who is who and I think
it could hardly be
easier so very simply we
manage to take advantage of the power of the
reliability of mathematical calculations in
dahouët not thematic to and of and d  a
fairly substantial financial instrument valuation library
like that of our risks